[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ou à maïté on va pas
pouvoir commencer cette émission n'a pas
fait le ménage regarder ce désordre
qu'est ce que c'est que cette espèce de
truc
et ce par les désordres se décarcasse
c'est parce qu'aujourd'hui on va faire
avec des restes des restes de volailles
ont des choses que vous avez une
certaine audace de nous montrer ses
morceaux quand même non c'est pour bien
faire voir qu'on dit toujours rejeté
hier la preuve regardez ça mais qu'est
ce qu'on va laver l'intention de faire
avec ses rêves faire une quiche de
volaille
oui voilà là sur la lâchant d'envoi du
chapon face au japon on réserve mais on
peut fermer du poulet riz du canard avec
tout ce qu'on veut pourvu qu'on ait du
plan de deux ans l'attend ça et puis on
va faire après une soupe aux coquillages
ou maïté on en a déjà fait ça oui mais
c'est pas la même c'est pas rassasié le
problème c'est une recette polynésienne
et on va la faire à notre façon avec ce
qu'on a
en essayant de jouer parce qu'on avait
dit qu'on a un a mis la barre à ce qu'on
voit la cuisine des mousquetaires à
tahiti et nous a dit comment faire cette
soupe ce moment là bas on l'a fait avec
des très gros coquillage et russe au
lieu de nous dans les coraux on les
appelle des bénitiers
elles ont refermé d'optimalité il paraît
qu'ils ont un manteau ou bleu vert
extrêmes même le temps là bas mais c'est
bon alors on va interpréter cette
recette puisque stamm et nous a expliqué
comment on peut remplacer les bénitiers
par des coquillages de chez nous de
france le l'atlantique
alors quels sont les produits qu'il vous
faut pour faire ces deux recettes
voilà rendus recette tout mélanger pour
la soupe de coquillages et brimé nous
allons rentrer dans l'ordre dans l'ordre
alors il faut du verglas
il faut de l'armagnac il faut des 40 du
poireau et en avait il faut de l'oignon
il faut des raisins il faut des pommes
de terre il faut bien entendu tous ces
petits corps a besoin de coquillages
marrant parce que c'est pas tous les
mêmes
l'ours et du copinage et la revoilà
mêmes vous avez registre l'es18
avec ce cône à risque rona voilà des
oeufs bien entendu et les carcasses de
volaille très bien et par quoi allez
vous commencer par la tisch on va faire
la pâte
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut de la farine 2
e du beurre 1 n'a vraiment un pays du
sel du poivre
là moi je sers des jeux partout voilà on
va mettre des oeufs dans les métiers
entier bien sûr j'en ai blanc oui là
ces trois joueurs mais ça va être trop
vous croyez ça a tenté de farine
après le beurre que je vais couper comme
ça et on va tout y est il faut pas que
je me mettrais bien et je crains que ce
soit difficile alors que pour mélanger
tout ça ouvre au china parra passait
dans le liquide
il faudra ajouter un tout petit peu
doute peut-être un petit peu la revoilà
regarder ça c'est joli un petit peu
d'eau
en faire une jolie boule et ensuite
l'état lara et si on n'a pas de rouleau
à pâtisserie on prendra une bouteille
parce que ça marche aussi bien meilleur
sur n'a fait la guerre nous et vous la
voulez très fine
mais il faut ni trop fils denis trophée
paix quand même et donc sa lancée la
paix avec tout ce qu'on va mettre dedans
lancé pour vous la mettez dans un moule
beurré 6 mai aurait pu tomber sur des
moules et après et après on fait ça là
voilà on épouse bien le bords du moule
et big ben là je vous regarde pas et
papa coup voilà d'autres vins soit parce
que j'appelle a pas d'argent c'est votre
mère et votre corps qui vous ont montré
pour la faire comme ça là pour avoir le
bac je sais pas monsieur
le plus curieux c'est comme on l'a fait
dans votre famille mais partout où on ne
fait comme ça voilà et on va la mettre
au four tout le monde fait ça je reçois
ça prend pas ça se fait automatiquement
sait pas faire autrement en région on
les fait différemment à bbb oui mais la
voilà
allez on va faire cuire ça il faut
surveiller bon il n'a plus qu'à préparer
pendant quatre ans qu'on va mettre
dedans
oui vous avez vidé oignons à rissoler et
puis on est en train de déployer ces
carcasses en face et reste de volailles
que vous coupez en petits morceaux a
grandi morceaux alors qu'est ce que vous
allez en faire les oignons c'est bon je
vais y mettre tout ce que l'on ne
connaît pas la peau
non je voulais deux secondes viande moi
je l'aimais la pauvre on est là dans le
dos il est morte ou qui sont très bon
dimensionnement de s'en priver
xavier réussissent très bien allez c'est
bon là je vais parler saler poivrer
puisque le chapon il est prêt alors je
prends les rayons vous mettez pas un peu
de jus avant oui on va le mettre en
route mais il veut avant tout prendre
c'est pas un nom alors les raisins on va
éviter l'armagnac l'arrêt métro parce
que ça faisait bien imbibé là
vraiment ça tient à faire un bon mélange
tout ça on les résas maïté il faut dire
quand même c'était des raisins frais où
elle a une plaie et puis on les avait
été filmée et on les avait fait 30 et
voilà pendant au moins deux heures dans
l'armagnac alors l'alexandrin mais on
peut les trouver en voir pelé tout est
payé des californiens mais à moins de
goût devrait empêcher bien milliards
d'apports cela fait il faut un peu de
patience quand même voilà allez merci
pour tout vous dire que si un petit peu
de vert là et on va laisser mijoter tous
à grains qui demandent pas trop
longtemps parce qu'au fond le poulet
médias cuit les oignons ils sont déjà
revenus presque parfait le vert il faut
diffuser un petit peu et c'est le vin
que donner son petit goût et les voisins
faut pas qu'ils cuisse trop voilà on a
sorti la patte du fou prix puis prévu
tout à fait quid une face à une minute
elle y est restée là et la regarder mais
là le vin a réduit le verra réduit tout
appris beaucoup
regardez-moi ça la finlande va mettre
ceux-ci comme cela les restes de
volaille vous allez les égaliser
légaliser la bière ça suffit je voulais
aller un peu loin moi ou pendant ce
temps qu'est ce que vous savez des
bosses jaune de faire on va tous les ans
depuis que j'ai 8 ans les jeunes et
c'est sûr que vous la ramenez le
rajouter quelque chose comme il faut
pour une piscine voilà alors un petit
peu de poivre un petit peu de sel et de
la grimace à vélo de tram train on avait
tout d'abord il faut tout à fait pas de
cible voilà c'est bon je voulais verser
dessus
oui on est sur les gaspillages pour bien
mélanger et ça y est on va arroser
abondamment et bien entendu on a laissé
le four allumé dessus parce qu'on va
passer ça pendant pas très long car même
en ce sens si ce jour minutes 10 minutes
il faut que ça veut dire que les écuries
non
voilà vous le mettez au four joly a
besoin de pas vous brûler sa boîte chaud
encore
donc non ça va voilà bon ben ça c'est
très bien dix minutes à four chaud et
maïté qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant
et bien la soupe de coquillages vous
avez coupé des zones très très faim et
puis vous avez été patient parce que
vous aviez attendu bien là ça soit bien
dorer l'oignon c'est laura cuir et
rigoler temps quand il est cuit ça donne
un peu plus de saveur
l'artiste que vous ajoutez alors la
météo et légumes carottes poireaux et
n'avait pas bien que je vais mettre ici
de tout ensemble ça va faire le faire la
soupe avec les pommes de terre voilà
couper un petit moussilou et original
rypien faut l'arroser avec quelque chose
quand même nom tout ça qu'est ce qu'une
sous là avec casimir à lanzhou et arosa
me dis que j'ai un petit peu de serre et
de pop se serait bien relevé et là on a
fait un fumée un délicieux fumet de
poisson qu'il a deux dents sur une tête
de con draoui ça c'est pas très bon à
manger le congrès des fumées délicieux
excédent a naturellement vous aviez mis
aussi avec cette tête de congre vous
êtes dit me rue de l'église à blanc gris
blanc de vin blanc de l'oignon doux de
girofle du thym du laurier voilà une
carotte tout ce qu'il faut voilà on va
laisser cuire sa panda pendant pendant
une bonne demi heure pour vous couvrir
vous mélangez et couvrir en leur honneur
ajoute rien puisqu'il ya tout et on va
maintenant s'occuper des coquillages
nous avons ouvert les huîtres maïté wii
qui sont des huit je crois du bassin
d'arcachon ombre peut-être du banc
d'arguin même oui voilà elles vous
plaisent qu'est ce que vous en faites
sont un peu revenus mais cela est un peu
enrhumé les bons alors dans la soupe
c'est à dire dans les légumes qu'ils
cuisent avait le fut mais je vais les
mettre dedans ça fr vous dire bien sûr
ça va être pas de très bons 6 1 il a si
longtemps ça ça bien sympa qu'on très
bon parce que si elles cuisent trop mais
ça fait rire c'est pour une petit bout à
bout c'est pourtant d'un juste un petit
gouvernement que ce soit très cuit vous
inquiétez pas cela souvent le petit des
petits plus alors la bouillir elles vont
cuire et on recouvre et voilà et les
coquillages on n'est pas dedans
non je vais les mettre dans le fut mais
alors là nous avons les clés
c'est très joli un assez cher et paraît
à lévis mais ça nous quand on aime on
comptera alors non mais là il n'ya pas
le plus beau le plus gros et on va aller
ça on appelle ça des amendes jolie dans
toutes ses couleurs
oui encore une merveille de la nature
allez-y tout est beau et bon voilà et là
on va attendre qui s'ouvre qui s'ouvre
et après vous allez voir ce qu'on va en
faire deux trois minutes ont suffi ils
sont bien parce qu'ils ne sont pas trop
cuisent n'ai pas besoin de le croquer
soulageant comme il juste ouvert qu'est
ce que vous faites maintenant alors la
soupe elle elle est prête à rouler avec
les poètes et les twitter je vais là
passée et après ce sera plus jolie ou et
puis advienne tels que le vieux passe
purée pour ce genre de samhain allemand
a oui on avance des trucs
extraordinaires et on revient on
voudrait bien mais bien sûr je dis qu
qui voudriez vous les préparez vous les
mettez un petit à côté de vous et puis
voilà
ils savaient qu'ils sont beaux ces
coquillages jolie et le groupe aurait
dit qu'ils étaient très frais en poche
ils ont juste le nom du valais pour être
ouverts mais cette apparence de frais
qui est tellement agréable de broglie
j'en ai envie d un début je voudrais
bien goûté ça quand vous voulez vous
savez qu'on dit que les gens pour moi en
bon caractère on m'a dit ça alors ça m'a
beaucoup consoler plaisir aussi
ben oui alors envoyé des gens qui font
le mauvais sourire sur la nourriture il
faut bonifier n'y a pas que ça ne va pas
avec eux la voilà regarder ça c'est joli
alors si coquillages que vous mettez
ouvrir des coquilles et l'avc contredit
âge on doit les mettre dans la soupe
voilà et vous direz que l'on forme ça
c'est normal ils sont plus lourds et
sans merci
et puis maintenant il ne reste plus qu'à
présenter latif elle est magnifique
sam a été chaude secondes votre avis est
fait avec des restes et ben c'est l'art
d'accommoder layrac voilà alors on voit
très bien les raisins on voit les petits
morceaux de réussite de volaille
les touches konami de bons qu'on en
avait avec m alors on peut l'accompagner
avec très jolie salade verte de la tonne
à la jolie batavia ou bien quelques
petites tomates est comme entrer la
soupe de coquillages qui était
excellente
très bonne volée en fait alors gros
appétit on prend la souris la tige petit
à petit les i pour un dîner la quiche et
la salade avec ça vous êtes content au
revoir et à bientôt bon appétit
[Musique]